[Music]
since we're nitpicking this incredible
show anyway why the [ __ ] does morty have
a coat hung up on the wall here does he
really have no closet or is this a
trophy from a serial killing rick turns
on a light but the obvious light on the
ceiling does not light up coming from
some magical source in a room with only
one switch
oh i got a surprise for you come on
hurry up gotta go gotta go you gotta get
out you're tugging me too hard
exact conversation i had with my college
girlfriend during jean-claude van damme
night at our local bdsm
film dungeon somehow makes it into the
show look if you want to know what we're
up against here the mother
moon is drawn with such care here that
they included the phasing shadow the
level of thought that went into this
show is astounding well played show
well played i built it out of stuff i
found in the garage did you though the
trashcan and the flashlight sure but i'm
pretty sure you had to get this high
density bubble glass and these giant
screws custom-made where did you find
the giant cylinder base for the
spaceship in the garage
it also looks like most of the stuff
that you attach to this thing wouldn't
aid in flying but hinder it why would
rick even install seat belts in the
first place does he strike you as the
kind of person while throwing together a
junk-crafted space-time ship in his
garage stops for a second and thinks but
first
safety how are these two so close when
rick clearly landed several feet away
when he fell out of the ship
opening title spoilers also i know rick
and morty wears its references on its
sleeve but this opening theme song
couldn't be more doctor who if tom baker
and david tennant were in a threesome
with the ghost of william hartnell while
russell t
davies watched also also intro promises
an episode where morty is a robot and
doesn't come through ever there are two
or three other things in this the intro
promises and doesn't deliver and i'm
calling my local adult swim about it why
is this pink liquid or the smith
drinking pepto for breakfast
i mean with this family i guess that
might make sense i mean if you told me
jerry ends up mixing it with whiskey and
has a fondness for barbed wire
i wouldn't say you were wrong two plus
two jessica hilarious that rick said
that school was exactly this and it
happens as soon as morty gets to school
but this isn't the first day is it what
did they get taught in the time leading
up to this
you know what i named these my little
mortys do you know what i want you to do
with them
rename them honestly this kind of joke
deserves a sin removal but he's dreaming
about this so he's dreaming about
jessica showing him her boobs having her
call them her little morty's and then
negging her for it it's like he mastered
neil strauss's the game but is only good
at it when he's dreaming
we got we gotta get get the hell out of
here and go take care of business
what's with dirty sanchez always having
goop in his mouth and the constant
belching with this level of acid reflux
i'm guessing rick's ulcers are on the
verge of ending his life i'm just saying
if we don't find out in a future episode
that the belching and the mouth splooge
is actually caused by an
interdimensional species that lives in
his gut bacteria i'll lose a lot of
respect for the show
now if you just stick with me morty
we're gonna be holy crap morning run
predator pauses predatoring prioritizing
panic and protagonist punchline past
partaking of perfectly palatable people
we're gonna die
first act ends on a cliffhanger for a
commercial break only to return with
rick and morty no longer in danger and
the monster gone
and nobody mentioning it again and sure
that could be some sort of comedic point
about the worthlessness of commercial
cliffhangers but you think a show like
this might acknowledge
it a little bit just take these shoes
morty i convenience them out of my lab
coat of conveniences
these things really bring it all
together
you have to turn them on morty sure rick
looks like a total [ __ ] for not
telling morty about turning the shoes on
before he fell into the ravine but
morty's kind of an [ __ ] for being
this trusting of rick and deciding to
dive in head first without even a
question
morty survives this is he immortal yeah
it's a cartoon i get it but in what
alternate universe can a leg broken in
at least three places continue to stay
elevated like this
i went into a future dimension with such
advanced medicine
that they had broken legs here i'm at
every corner drugstore nice echoing of
the back to the future line there but
what kind of place is it that people are
breaking their legs so much
that a broken leg serum is a viably
mass-produced medicine rick separates
this seed but there is somehow a full
seed in each half now
knowing this show that could completely
be intentional and is some sort of
paradoxical joke that will be retconned
into a story line in season 42 but the
pickens here be slim so for now
i'm gonna need you to take these seeds
into the bathroom and i'm gonna need you
to put them way
up inside your butthole morty already
full of grace they'll fall right out of
mine
i've done this too many times morty sure
rick is a quasi-evil drunken [ __ ] and
an unreliable character overall but
didn't he tell morty what do you think i
can just do it all by myself
and now he's saying he's done this lots
of times maybe rick just wanted to spend
time with morty i'll grant that but i'm
taking my sin and going home
come on morty please morty you have to
do it morning man rick says morty at
least a hundred times in this first
episode
i'm sure it's on purpose for some sort
of comedic effect but damn the effect
wears off quick
why didn't you notify us have you not
been getting the messages i've been
leaving with morty's grandfather
sure this principle is dumb but if he's
been calling morty's grandfather and
leaving messages that apparently have
been going unheeded for two months
wouldn't you try and call the parents at
work isn't that how you got in contact
with them this time
wait is there just an unguarded portal
just lying around at this airport no
employees no other people waiting in
line
oh look honey it's our son with albert
ein douche
i mean dickel the tesla was right there
but sure whatever sure this background
joke is hilarious because it's a towing
company that has a mascot that's a toe
with eyes named toe whose catchphrase is
ito which could both be interpreted as i
am doing towing as well as hello my name
is toe but the important thing to note
here is that toes don't bend like that
i didn't know hanging out with you is
making me smarter temporary super
intelligence is just a side effect of
the mega seeds dissolving in your rectal
cavity oh really then why did morty only
show super intelligence when you asked
him questions to fool his mom and dad
feels rather convenient but how can i
hate this show
the synths don't matter and i needed
those seeds real bad not in this episode
you didn't meaning those seeds are
about the mcguffinious thing to ever
mack all over my guppies
boy you really got me up against the
wall this time jerry
look i'm fine with the speed at which
rick made this smart dog helmet but he
must have already had this thing built
except for like one screw to simply go
to his garage and use a drill for two
seconds and produce a finished product
go to the bathroom
not sure how impressive that is he
clearly just flushed the toilet because
he didn't have time to climb on top of
it and actually use it
geez rick and the time it took you to
make this thing couldn't you've just you
know
helped me with my homework morty would
be amazing at tv since
i mean the guy teaches high school
method i didn't take him for an active
dreamer
i see someone hasn't seen stand and
deliver that's on you rick summer's
phone shows snuffles very close to jerry
but he somehow ends up two feet away
from him when it cuts
to the next shot oh yeah this should
play out just fine
you said the same thing equally
sarcastically at our wedding and guess
what is it just me or is the jerry and
beth marriage
way sadder than it is funny also sitcom
husband constantly does and says stupid
things sitcom wife gets irritated with
them to the point where no one
understands how they would have ever
gotten married in the first place and
had kids but somehow they make it work
just barely cliche why would i negotiate
with you
because we're both rational adults that
don't want anything bad to happen
and because i have a human shield how is
rick able to human shield mrs pancakes
since she was clearly behind mr
goldenfold when all this started
golden fold landed the plane and he's
created a mechanical arm to pluck mrs
pancakes out of the air while he lets us
fall into a giant vanilla
absurd and funny i think morty's ability
to know exactly what golden fold did
and give a full report of it is what
sells it i'll just go ask her to tell
golden fold not to kill us when she
wakes up whoa whoa morty
the trick to incepting is making people
think they came up with the idea oh
really then what was that on the
airplane then when you pretended you
were going to blow it up how was that
top notch incepting rick
looks like goldenfold has some
predilection so shameful he buries them
in the dreams of the people in his
dreams
i don't think goldenfold is nearly that
shameless about his fantasies you
remember the first episode that guy was
just standing there while morty
unconsciously grabbed his boobs and he
leaned into it
at school looks like some sort of
legally safe knockoff of an 80s horror
character
with miniature swords for fingers
instead of knives why would he need to
be legally safe rick why would he need
to be legally safe
okay fine god damn it this show is
clever and funny and all the things
three sends off it was only with years
of selective breeding and genetic
altering
that this noble beast was transformed
into man's subservient little buddy
convenient tv's position is convenient
there are my testicles summer first off
why is snuffles terrorizing summer of
all people over this
second off as a super genius dog you
damn well know where your testicles went
buddy you shall now call me
snowball because my fur is pretty and
white snowball must have gotten this
idea when researching video clips about
david duke
let's go where the [ __ ] was this [ __ ]
the whole time do you mean the snuffle
snowball meant to go in and chastise
summer over things she wasn't
responsible for hope her parents would
wake up and go into a room to see what
the matter was then dramatically reveal
this other dog when the time was right
we're trying to get me to get an a in
math so how is rick planning on getting
morty a's in all of his other classes is
he just going to inception every one of
morty's teachers every year of school
inception marathon inception thon
he keeps saying we can run but we can't
hide like if the truth was that we could
hide
it's not like he'd be sharing that
information with us you know this is a
hilarious rick and morty discussion
about a trope in horror movies that
characters never really think about but
i'm wondering why they can hide when
scary terry has been popping out of
nowhere throughout this inception dream
sequence in places where he shouldn't
know where they are
hi honey you're home early how was your
day i have a lot of questions about this
little life that's occurring in a dream
inside a dream inside a dream inside a
dream but mainly
i want to know how these not krueger's
use hand soap get off my back [ __ ] and
septic abuse
i love you melissa i love you too terry
why is this boner look while my sinhat
wants to question everything about
what's in this room right now this
domestic scene for scary terry and the
claw marks that are everywhere that
suggest a sex life that is better than
yours or mine deserves a sin-off for
detail and hilarity
this must be a dream because we just saw
this teacher push open a door with a
doorknob on it makes sense because he
ain't turning that doorknob
don't even trip about your pants dog
here's a pair on us full
and where exactly did morty get the
pants from because i combined many
things that happened in this episode but
morty getting bright enough to know how
to mediate the dream within a dream
world is not one of them these halves
don't belong together [ __ ]
that's interesting this is because you
don't give morty smith good grades [ __ ]
so i know they're making fun of
inception in this episode but even while
they're making fun of it rick was
adhering to inception's rules about
making it seem like the person came up
with the idea on their own so i don't
know how the scary terry rocket suddenly
puts the idea of giving morty better
grades into mr goldenfold's head that
makes him think he came up with it i'm
entertained mind you but this seems to
be going against the rules of even an
inception spoof
i know one thing for sure i'm giving
morty an
a in math that's great but what is the
wet mr golden fold shirt since all he
had was a bowl of wheat thins they just
couldn't do this thing without a dog's
playing poker reference could they
well at least i didn't really crap my
pants no no that happened before you
went to sleep morty
you're sleeping in your crap right now
wait was that even something that
happened i don't remember morty saying
he crapped his pants at any time in this
episode until now like it's something
that we were supposed to be aware of
already sounds like you just wanted to
wallow in
a little bit joe it's pretty bad emperor
snowball we're gonna need to do another
operation
if snowball snuffles is so smart then
clearly he would know this is rick
behind the dog mask i see dogs walking
out of an animal shelter into a war to
some other dimension but is this
supposed to be all dogs or just the ones
in rick and morty's town also this puts
the onus on the series to never show
dogs in this world ever again
i could just send holiday inflatables
because seriously how did that become a
thing but it's much easier to send the
fact that you put rudolph right in the
middle of your
driveway also you shovel an immaculate
path to the sidewalk but only half of
your driveway what are you monsters
put it in the stocking summer or i'm
joining facebook
a teenager caring about facebook you're
adorable 2013
also facebook is this a mirror at the
bottom of the stairs was the goal to
both check your appearance as well as
block traffic in the most dangerous part
of your home
okay look i know the show is going for a
quick joke here with his giant morty
melon somehow fitting through that
opening but why does the show go to
great detail with some areas of physics
but approach this one by literally
jamming its head of its hole
just hold your breath until the process
is over or your lungs will collapse
and then he doesn't and yet he's fine
hey dad where's morty
he's busy yeah great joke and all but
even beth should be a little surprised
at the naked near-death bad santa whose
chest her dad currently has a giant
needle jammed into right
welcome to anatomy park roll come
warchills the anatomy park train has
only one small entrance exit for a train
with three cars and what the [ __ ] is up
with these stairs with no rails that
lead to your certain doom if you fall
i love details like a partner dust sign
for an amusement park inside a human
body and i'm certainly laughing but who
is this sign for the park isn't open yet
and doesn't appear to be close to
opening so there are no customers
affected by it and if the park has been
open this whole time we're talking about
a logistical nightmare from the
customers getting shrunk and enlarged at
the smith house without anyone seeing it
and figuring out where the hell homeless
reuben is to inject them into his body
reuben's seen some rough years morty
don't judge you don't agree to have a
theme park built inside you if your
life's going great
why is this saying not a t-shirt who are
you why would this guard be concerned
with anybody who shows up here not like
anyone can illegally trespass into this
homeless person's body unless rick
specifically inserts them it's weird
that the security guy here
shoots bullets at diseases instead of
like vaccines or penicillin
can we talk about jerry's sweater for a
second the colors in the middle section
should be reversed so that the red
sections are green and look like
christmas trees unless of course these
are intentional green arrows pointing
down
to an entirely different type of
christmas cheer i watch them sometimes
from a chair
and sometimes from a closet almost
always dressed as superman cut ken
nearly all human lungs contain a strain
of these bacteria but the scar tissue
keeps them dormant if the scar tissue's
already been tampered with then why did
the tuberculosis wait until germ oliver
said something about it to attack what
is that horrible smell
must be your own breath because you're
breathing air from inside your helmet
from the attached air supply so smell
really shouldn't be an issue
keep your eye on annie she was written
up several times by her manager at the
churro stand
later on annie will say actually i
studied dr bloom's work so did she get
written up because she was constantly in
dr bloom's lab learning everything seems
like someone who was allowed to study
the work of the main boss wouldn't be
stuck at the turos stand getting written
up for whatever reason this also seems
to indicate that the park was open but i
still haven't gotten a definitive answer
on that
[Music]
rhyming food with good gonorrhea can't
see us
if we don't move wait i was wrong i was
thinking t-rex
why the [ __ ] would you be thinking of a
goddamn t-rex because of the movie
jurassic park that you're referencing
throughout the episode like dinosaurs
and infectious diseases are in any way
related enough to confuse the two
if it works we'll be regular sized in a
few minutes you mean there's a growth
ray inside reuben this guy jokes about
ruben not being in a room with white
carpet or upholstery and good for the
show for thinking of the gnarly
aftermath of such a move but
seems like in a world of impossible
science they'd have found a way to
escape without the grizzly measure
that's bubonic plague so a couple
questions here
first why did you leave it roaming free
in your backpack pocket if you had this
plan to sell bubonic plague to the
highest bidder
wouldn't you have a container to put it
in second why the hell was there bubonic
plague inside ruben what the hell
[Music]
i'm sorry does the grandfather really
think that his wife and jacob are going
to have sex right now on the couch while
his granddaughter and her boyfriend make
out in the same room the aristocrats
also did these closet door flaps open
individually like this or
even at all would you like to ride the
bone train why are you doing this bit
we're going to die morty would be
retorting at tv sins what the hell
is that e coli outbreak is it though
because those are clearly bacteriophage
viruses and
e coli is a type of bacteria and not a
virus suck my fat virology expertise
rick wads
would this fuse continue being lit while
in space my guess is no but i should
probably send myself or even thinking
about it when it comes to an episode
about an amusement park inside of a
homeless man
reports from all over the country have
been coming in about what appears to be
a giant naked man over the continental
united states
how fast did those reports come in
exactly rick just kicked him out of the
spaceship and enlarged him like three
seconds ago i'm pretty sure that
dynamite would have exploded before any
news outlets had the chance
to make their detailed naked guy graphic
overlays i guess i'm gonna have to be
that guy and point out that ruben is now
the size of the entire continental us
so his face should be covering way more
area than a city block
the nipple hole it's beautiful
agreed but i have to ask why is there
even gravity now that interspace has
gone to outer space
what the f when the bone train went off
the rails hepatitis a was looking at it
go past him and crash into this nipple
area
even if he jumped to grab the train how
would he have gotten inside and the time
it took for the train to crash
it's hepatitis c did we have some sort
of relationship with him
i think they're just like that i think
they're just good guys
that's hilarious i'll gladly remove the
sin wouldn't this life as rough picture
show the golf ball
actually in the rough rather than on the
green where the hole is actually
i studied dr bloom's work i i i believe
i have the knowledge necessary to create
an entirely new much safer park jurassic
world
that's it that's the sin
that's atari 2600 donkey kong sounds
coming from these 2013 devices it's time
to upgrade our gadget noises hollywood
this is just sloppy craftsmanship rick
would be excellent at biology sins
also dissecting a rodent with the garage
door open what's with
mom so you're saying that she's acting
weird on a good day everyone acts weird
in the world of rick and morty yet still
i have to ask
why is rick digging in this rat he knows
he's in a simulation he knows the rat
has sloppy craftsmanship so what is he
looking for
he doesn't need more proof celebrating
math
also wearing an orange shirt and gray
tie with a yellow sweater
interesting peeking into a child's
classroom window as an adult also since
rick knows morty is a simulation why is
he going through this charade at the
school
rick would immediately be getting the
nigerians to show their hands so he
could plan his escape
you know if you tell us i'll be your
girlfriend
oh you will seems like a rare
opportunity
morty simulation or not so listening sex
from a student for bribing purposes will
always be a sin
take a shower with me morty what at
times like these i wonder how the
writers begin their creative process
does it start with let's put child
nudity in this one do they have a jar
containing tiny strips of paper with
random bull
suggestions aimed at making everyone
incredibly uncomfortable and at the
start of their brainstorm they grab
several and slap them together
why is this scene lucky for us they're
also really uncomfortable with nudity i
just want to know how rick knew the
location of the school showers in the
first place
i go through all the trouble of
animating this split-second peak into
the locker room and not put anything
interesting in it at all
something is drawing a lot of processing
power you have more important things to
worry about alien scum
these fans aren't cooling the computers
properly they're limping along sort of
teeter-tottering back and forth and
before long your cpus will overheat it's
a real problem
trimming your nose hair while driving
i'm not sure that i can ask this
question without breaking my own brain
but here goes
why is jerry separated from rick from
the start they're both inside the same
simulation and yet the aliens are
surprised that they've got another human
they're literally looking down on a
massive simulation with two simultaneous
simulations happening within it there
should be no surprise that jerry's here
at all
are the writers hoping to avoid
revealing the twist to us the viewers
or the aliens purposely zooming out on
jerry's inner simulation
to rick's inner simulation forgetting
what is real at all
are we in the simulation two
i broke my brain keep your hands off
your ding-dong it's the only way we can
speak freely
because for some reason the aliens are
unable to simply listen to the
conversation
they must look and listen national apple
farmers of america
welcome to our ad agency but how would
the nigerians know this much detail
about jerry's work day when they didn't
even mean to nab him
and on top of that they only have a
simulation operating at 0.5
capacity simple question gentlemen
assuming gender
this scene just reminds me that dave
ramsey has forever tainted the beauty
that is baker street
king dave ramsey well all is forgiven
because right now i've got an erection
the size of an east coast lighthouse hey
i'm going to make love to my wife how
big does jerry think lighthouses are
because i'm not even seeing evidence
that a pup tent has been pitched relax
it's just a bunch of ones and zeroes out
there binary code shaming
leaving your car door open is sex really
worth giving someone the opportunity to
steal your car or running the battery
down
actually yeah i guess it is but for the
principle of the matter i'm still a
synonym
making out with dead skin cells excreted
from a scalp i would definitely be on to
the simulation after seeing this
everyone knows yellow pop-tarts can't
jump de-panting a child rather than
yourself
pop-tart squarepants moments ago they're
running through an alien spaceship and
quite suddenly they're racing through
another planet
we don't care about plutonians we care
about why jerry is here at all
moments ago they're running through an
alien spaceship and quite suddenly
they're racing on the moon
we don't care about the moon landing we
care about why the plutonians are here
at all
man up jerry i may need you to work the
lasers putting jerry in charge of the
lasers
doors are closing and time is running
out but the protagonist's spaceship
makes it out just in time cliche
oh because shooting at the person you
want to steal information from is a
great idea
and yes this is a simulation inside a
simulation inside a simulation
but the darkness of it still matters you
simulated my grandson's genitalia
you looked at your grandson simulated
genitalia you win
can we go home now i don't know can you
grammar police
sure we do it too but we actually spent
five years at grammar police academy to
get our certification
up until now i had to brush off my
frustration with english appearing in
the alien spaceship
clearly they have their own language we
see it here and here so when the signs
were in english or the doors were
labeled i had to brush it off that this
was a simulation
and meant to continue to deceive rick
but now here in this moment before
extinction
there is no reason for we did it to
appear on the screens for our benefit
also there is no reason for this mixture
to be combined at the helm of the ship
during an office party when there are
plenty of labs up in this ship
also also rick and jerry survive this
waggling your tongue when you really
don't need to
i already told you it's not your family
sure but can we talk about what they're
trying to do because not jerry seems to
have you well in his grip
and able to kill you easily but is just
standing there waiting for this scene
that's just an excuse to justify a title
sequence clip to end
why would this facility as part of its
infrastructure have a button that
remotely controls this ghostbusters
style trap that rick had in his hand
isn't that something he just brought to
the adventure you make a request the me
seeks fulfills the request
and then it stops existing rick knowing
about this me seeks box makes so many of
his previous decisions in this show
completely unnecessary as disposable as
these beings are why wouldn't he use
them as at least an extra pair of hands
to complete all his adventures with
morty
i'm mr macy i want to be popular at
school oh
okay this me seek schtick is a brilliant
way to play with the be careful what you
wish for trope but in a world where the
genie allows you to wish for infinite
wishes god this show is just the best
this village is terribly poor yet the
giant that lives in the clouds above has
untold treasures jeff bezos also this
world not only happens to have
the jack and the beanstalk story from
our earth in its reality but rnm also
just happened to land in the village
where he lives just a reminder that even
the most brilliant shows need some
little blue convenience pills once in a
while to keep their stories firmed up
in conclusion a friendship with silly
smith is the most valuable
and enriching experience of your young
lives mr meeseeks was able to call an
assembly at summer school just to say
great things about her so that she'd be
popular and it looks like the entire
school is on board with a magical blue
whatsit they've never seen before in his
pro summer message
also holy hell what kind of acid trip
was the designer of this basketball
court on the key area or free throw dick
as it's more commonly called
is completely out of proportion and
reaches almost a half court which would
be fine except the other half of that
chord appears to be more like a third of
the chord and doesn't even seem to have
any markings plus that far hoop which is
clearly not retracted and should be at
the standard 10 feet has to be at least
20 feet off the ground based on the
scale of the bleachers underneath it
and speaking of those bleachers why are
they behind the podium when all the
space in front of the podium is
available and how did they even get them
there they clearly don't fold in so did
they move this here in one piece this is
a gymnasium of lies
i know jerry is a dim-witted sad sack
but wouldn't shaving two strokes off his
golf game suggest that he's somewhat
competent in golf if the guy can't even
hit the ball off the tee
then isn't the real request shave a
thousand strokes off his golf game
let me try something why did they bring
the mesex box with them on the golf
course do they expect to need extra mr
me seeks during this tutorial
can you help me get two strokes off in
jerry's golf swing
but if the miseqs are aware of their own
process and abilities enough to call
other musics to help with what i asked
them to do wouldn't that impact their
perspective on their own purpose in a
way that negates my original request i
guess what i'm asking is how many seeks
would a miseq seek if a me seek could
seek me a rick and morty from a
spider-verse because i don't know how
you climb a mostly flat surface like
that without a little accidental
radioactive spider venom me seeks don't
usually have to exist this long
it's getting weird how does he even know
this i've about had it with the discount
blue man group's existential paradoxes
here we are you know walking down the
courthouse steps why would the
courthouse steps lead all the way down
to the non-giant world below wouldn't
the steps that the giant court lead to
other places where the giants regularly
go
also did everyone else in the courts
just stay inside was the rick and morty
trial the undercard to a much more
important trial
why did jerry bring everybody back to
the house for his lesson how are you
supposed to learn this inside a living
room was he trying to hit a ball inside
his house was he just trying to swing
the club because i'm pretty sure he
succeeded at the second thing but what
do i know tennis confuses me what
happened to beth's new hair she had a
new style a minute ago and now it looks
like the old beth
why did you even rope me into this cause
he wrote me into this well
him over there he wrote me into this the
cinemasins hiring process
well what do you know look down there
looks like some kind of tavern or
something the thirsty step i mean the
12th step was sitting right there
stop fighting just let this happen holy
sh my surrealist sci-fi comedy show just
went super dark the creators have even
said they wanted this scene to reflect
the trauma of assault and not be funny
at all but here's my question is this
really the place for it i'm all for
victim sensitivity but seems to me the
most sensitive thing to do would be to
not
unexpectedly reference real-life trauma
in a place where most wouldn't be
expecting to have to deal with it these
me seeks are never given verbal
instructions are we changing the rules
so that they can just intuit what their
purpose is now we heard jerry leave the
house when he told them he seeks at this
point
my golf swing is more your problem than
mine
and he was wearing the green golf shirt
but now he's in a suit but wait neither
jerry nor beth told the musics where
they were going for dinner so maybe
after jerry left he went upstairs to get
dressed and came back down and told the
musics where they were going but why did
he clearly go outside after telling them
that there's only one door in the living
room that would open and close and it
goes outside
come on rick quick stalling
what do you guys read em and weep
rick slow rolls the stair folk rick
rolling at this point i'm kind of
wondering how the thirsty step stays in
business their location is awful and
most of its customers couldn't possibly
make it up here easily
[Music]
so we're just saying hitting a tomato
with a metal shelving bar into a large
pot about 10 feet away is equivalent to
improving your golf game two strokes
well
okay then jesus i didn't know the mean
seeks had such a huge arsenal did they
knock off a gun store on the way to the
restaurant or did the smiths have a
hidden gun room
i'm a bit of a stickler me seeks what
about your short games
and yet more proof that the mean seeks
get to decide when their purpose has
been fulfilled meaning they could have
bailed at any point and the entire
premise of this episode is null and void
and now that i've been this much of a
pedantic [ __ ] i can disappear
also the literal request was to shave
two strokes off of his game and jerry
got more than that by merely learning
how to drive the ball so go [ __ ]
yourself stickler me seeks your job
is technically done jerry look we don't
have a perfect marriage but
i'm not going anywhere define anywhere
see you next week everybody the fourth
wall is my least favorite wall yet i'm
sad somehow every time it gets broken
the mysteries of the heart confound us
letting jerry help morty with homework i
don't know how many times i have to say
this but if you have the flu
stay home does he mean stay home and
don't go to the dance or stay home and
don't go to school
because you shouldn't be at school if
you have the flu and if you're not at
school how would you hear this
announcement
why is this announcement also episode of
a cartoon from 2014 predicts how selfish
humans are when it comes to protecting
others from a rampaging virus
the flu season dance is about awareness
not celebration
you don't bring dead babies to passover
well someone's not getting invited to my
passover celebration
hey wait a minute where did jessica's
friends go
try not to worry about it morty you're a
good kid is he though
in this episode alone he asked rick to
help him essentially roofy jessica so i
think a little more honest parenting is
in order jerry
what the [ __ ] is the purple meat on
jerry's sandwich ah
well i remember feeling that way about a
young lady named your mom
and that's not an urban diss but it
works so much better as an urban diss
in fact that's a pretty epic your mom
joke that he just ruined
pink jerry we have ice we have no ice
rick is a dick to carbonated sodas wait
a minute did
rick go into the kitchen to get orange
juice
does rick seem like the kind of guy who
drinks orange juice without adding the
vodka
yeah i'm just going to check on your mom
and apparently leave out the mustard
mayo an open orange juice pitcher and an
unstarted sandwich
do you want food poisoning jerry because
this is how you get food poisoning jerry
and ants a hair morty i need one of your
hairs this isn't game of thrones
my favorite part of every episode of
game of thrones was when the csi team
came in and solved the case
there's a calculator of some sort on the
right side of this love potion making
machine here but when it cuts to the
wide shot the calculator is on the left
side of the spout your continuity errors
will be the death of you rick and morty
geez did this brad kid go to the dance
in his usual high school attire just
adding a tie that's actually pretty
funny but i'm singing it anyway
not that this is the point but shouldn't
brad already have the flu considering
jessica was already sneezing at school
today and he ran right into her sneeze
mist earlier
brad got sick immediately is that how
the flu works how come you're not at
this stupid dance everyone loves so much
screw that i don't want to get sick so
wait summer are you saying you're
backing out of our trip to south dakota
cartoon dry humping jessica get a hold
of yourself
the flu love potion combo which made
brad sick in second should already be
running
rampant through this gym considering it
was in the punch and the air
conditioning but it waits until someone
scolds jessica before taking over the
entire school
still being proud of a swimming
championship nearly a hundred years
later
whipped up an antidote it's based on
praying mantis dna they mate once and
then they you know decapitate the
partner
science i i basically mix this with a
more contagious flu virus why did you
need to mix it with a flu virus when
everybody at school already has the flu
these serums they don't work on anybody
related to you genetically i mean
thank god but that still is a serum of
the highest convenience
the only thing that is known is how cute
he is
i love him so much i want to make love
to him how did these news anchors even
get to their jobs if they were obsessed
morty loving praying mantis creatures
also where did they get a picture of
morty that quickly that's almost
creepier than the love potion
[Applause]
how is this virus already spread to
other countries the news station was
hard enough to buy but at least it was
potentially local
and this is going to be an issue for the
rest of the episode so instead of
bringing it up several more times i'll
just add 10 cents here
wait so everyone knows where morty lives
all of a sudden what the heck
is that a morty doll how did they
manufacture that well i'm glad we saved
all those horses
why did you short the glue industry how
did the flu mantis concoction get all
the way out to the horse hospital have
people been drive by sneezing around
this place
i'm mr crowbar and this is my friend
who is also a crowbar
i can't imagine a world where jerry
actually deserves a sin off but
i'm giving him one regardless if people
from other countries are whiffing the
antidote already wouldn't they have a
period of time when they turn back to
normal before morphing into these
abominations that's what happened to
everyone else
how did this guy's underwear stay on and
intact throughout all these
transformations
here's another thing rick made the love
potion for morty using his dna and
that's why his family wasn't affected
but he made the mantis potion in the
every animal on earth potion without
morty's dna so why aren't they also
turning into trauma creatures right now
hold on mad jerry fury road mad max
jerry road
furious jerry maximum mad max and
furious presents rhodes and shaw
the fury is there any reason for beth
and jerry to get out of the car and
fight these things
they were doing just fine running over
all of them what's the goal of coming
out to purposely kill these things other
than to pad this episode's run time
boy morty i really cronenberg the world
up didn't i don't be so hard on yourself
rick the world doesn't look too much
like him butterfly
here morty put this on while i do a
little bit of scouting why does morty
need to wear this thing while rick does
his scouting
what computer works just because
someone's wearing a backpack apparatus
okay so we're about to find out that
this is one of the infinite realities
that original rick found where a
parallel universe rick was able to get
everything back to normal
and the rick and morty we see here are
not the original rick and morty team
which is what the show wants you to
think so why is this universe's rick and
morty just now getting back to the house
after a newspaper was published
explaining how everything went back to
normal
the answer is don't think about it it's
not like we can do this every week
anyways we get three or four more of
these tops
yeah but that violates the cinemasins
and therefore tv sins charter where we
were told to think too deeply about it
it's too convenient
yes you don't follow the same rules and
you definitely shouldn't because nothing
creative would ever get made but that
doesn't mean that we're not sinning you
for this replace the dead rick and morty
in a different universe
bit i'd grown super fond of the original
summer beth and jerry and now i'm gonna
have to be cool with exact replicas with
no differences whatsoever you owe us an
apology
also you only get three or four more of
these tops has rick ever watched
anything on network television leaving
the refrigerator door
open he's got lifeless eyes black eyes
like a doll's eyes
glad summer could hopefully write jaws
on this box in case you didn't know the
reference but what happens when she
decides to do the englishman who went up
a hill but came down a mountain
not enough room on the box to explain
that reference then why would you need
these kind of lines in a galactic
parking lot shouldn't it just be a
series of different sized squares for
vertical landing and takeoff
also what's the deal with these parking
lot lights they're illuminating a
building that's already lit up and
neglecting the rest of the parking lot
i mean it's different from the stuff on
earth they have sex dolls on earth and
something tells me morty knows
way too much about that aliens on
another planet not only speak perfect
english but their stores have open and
closed signs written only in english
like what if you passed away or died or
something i wouldn't even have anything
to remember
all the cool stuff we did you know
remembering your late grandfather every
time you use your sex robot
so we're just going to pretend this
isn't happening well not with that
attitude we aren't
rick why would you let morty bring that
thing into our house i mean we know
jerry has no power but why did beth
allow it in the house
the real question for rick is why did
you buy that for morty in the first
place
really simply drinking from the carton
is a sin but it's doubled when you're
drinking from the carton after having
sex with an alien robot
sorry them's the rules intervening with
puberty you'll turn him into
ray finds and red dragon first it's
clearly ralph
fiennes i mean learn to pronounce things
but also referencing ralph fiennis from
red dragon
instead of tom noonan from manhunter
just a few seconds ago morty was
robo-railing so hard he had the
downstairs light swinging but these
knickknacks just stay put on his
headboard
i don't even know how these stay put
when he's not deep droiding this thing
could grow to the size of delaware
pretending like delaware is large
or exists i've gone too many episodes
without sending this and i can't hold
back anymore
that sock has never been moved from that
spot in the garage and it drives me
absolutely insane every time i see it
my therapist will be thankful i don't
have to discuss that with her anymore
portal question 253
if you can't see through the portal how
would this creature know exactly where
and how to grab
summer still think it's a good idea to
go through holes without a wiener
dub dub sorry just always wanted to do
that so
maybe a sin on me that's fair great now
i have to take over a whole planet
because of your stupid boobs
i can't tell if the show is aware and
poking fun at victim blaming or just
casually using it for a laugh and
considering the damage that kind of
thinking does every day this is either a
sin for the show's attitude or the
idiots who think this way
also watch what you're saying about
boobs mister those things are like
universally beloved he goes
tom hanks pizza then boobs and honestly
hanks and pizza better watch their back
why do tv families always store their
fruit so close to the floor
also storing bananas with your other
fruit is a terrible idea bananas release
a gas that makes other fruit spoil
quicker
crap that was actually somewhat
educational um bananas look like penises
saved it your hands bears your hands
title of my sex tape and that's how we
play
heavy hands oh you are going to ruin
that kid morty could be worse he could
be showing him caillou
what's the opposite of wubble up a dub
dubs am i right ladies and gentlemen
it's bad enough you're breaking the
fourth wall but now you're throwing test
questions our way too
i'm tired of zoom classes leave me alone
having a section of a newspaper simply
titled
news spider in sector c is still alive
plan your route accordingly and expect
delays so this world's just going to be
a bunch of sexist
jokes now i mean admittedly super
hilarious sexist jokes like
that restaurant that's called just a
bite of yours
the weather report said is anyone else
cold or is it just me
sorry i mean that's racist the females
are placed into educational programs the
males
they get to play outside the original
plot outline for boss baby somehow makes
its way into this episode
yeah you know what i have to say about
that
rick survives this fart can we talk
about these ear arms for a second
we've seen them active so we know they
aren't just vestigial so how does the
musculature work
part of the reason you can control your
arms is in the shoulders and chest
and sure maybe they have some thick
traps hiding under that hair but what
about the pecs shouldn't they have some
sort of chest muscles where their cheeks
would be
and that would mean they would also have
boobs there too six arms should mean six
boobs damn it also do you know how hard
it would be to hold your arms up like
that all day those arms should be
dangling down like flaccid fleshy
earrings
also also does this mean if they don't
apply deodorant they have bo right next
to their nose this is terrible design
and the god of this universe should be
punished to the maximum extent of
celestial law
was this really the time to make that
point summer kids
this is for you daddy well i guess we
know where this episode stands on the
whole nature versus nurture debate
good news parents what you do doesn't
make a difference only handcuffing four
of the six
arms and doing it via two separate
handcuff sets with a foot of chain
between them
and in front of the body this does
nothing
look at the tag read it where was that
tag hiding
and is that really where a tag would be
on a top like this mark
jacob these are names of the penis look
a lot of what these alien ladies are
saying about men is very true but we
give our penises
way more interesting names than mark or
jacob like boomerang or
big rick or count schlongula if you
think my top is cute
you cannot execute johnny cochraning
morty junior
smoking but where did he get the
cigarettes he hasn't gone outside no one
else in the house is a smoker
i don't want to masturbate i want to
conquer the planet oh just like this
generation and not be able to multitask
also this race is so horny they just
drop sex robots on them and then have
them all impregnated within minutes
so i think his murder boner would be
accompanied by a well
boner boner but first a deep sip from a
very tall glass of i told you so
those are gulps not sips you noisy and
biber
running wild running hot show makes fun
of motivating characters with songs and
that is just not acceptable without
survivor and robert pepper rocky would
have never been able to beat ivan drago
and don't you forget it also movie
steals the footloose scene from hot rod
hey stop that thinking honking your horn
will stop an alien monster from
destroying your car and potentially
killing you
i never got that impression from reading
marmaduke joe wants us to believe that a
kid in the 2010s would be reading
marmaduke
see you guys next week see everybody
next week this joke literally only works
one time the first time it airs unless
you're the kind of fan that plays your
blu-rays or streams weekly to be more
authentic
why don't you just prove you're a better
fan than the rest of us by having weekly
viewing parties where you can all quote
lines from the show and sing songs about
how great it is and
crap i just invented a religion didn't i
i know animation is tough guys but why
is the end table behind the couch now
when it was between them just a few
seconds ago you show us your concept of
good tv
and we'll crap all over that tv sim's
mission statement somehow ends up in the
script
didn't snowball and the other dogs in
this universe leave in episode two why
do the smiths still have this bed out
here sure it could be that they're just
too lazy to get rid of it but after a
quick cut away to jerry it's now gone
so that's a continuity error at least
one way and maybe even two you can
probably guess which way i'm leaning
how about showtime extreme in a world
where man evolved from corn welcome to
the rick and morty improv show with all
the hits and misses and improv show
entails it'll be just like the everyday
programming on channel 62 in the movie
uhf the fact that this gun was duct
taped to his back and yet the duct tape
somehow stays in place after he grabs it
to pop this other coin doesn't even have
a kernel of truth to it what too corny
letterman from a timeline where jerry's
famous they stumble upon shows that
directly relate to themselves on a tv
with infinite worlds and infinite shows
and i find that infinitely convenient
no the other thing go back really all
right fine why would the tv go back
immediately to the guy eating
when rick changed channels twice since
they ran across this disgusting [ __ ]
this episode is a treasure trove
of quick hilarious visual gags like
bottomless baseballs or a version of
game of thrones where everyone's a
little person except tyrion
i've never loved my pause button so much
in my life here these scan your retinas
and let you view parallel timelines
and i happen to be carrying this thing
around with me at all times check out
this refrigerator
only 200 pretty hilarious that because
ants in his eyes johnson can't see he
thinks the dryer is a refrigerator but
did anyone help him shoot the commercial
wouldn't someone correct him that he's
pointing at dryers this commercial isn't
being shot edited and broadcast live
although that would be quite the trick
i've heard of fire ants but are there
fireproof ants because those ants seem
just fine despite being engulfed in
flames
[Music]
i don't see anything there's a chance
you weren't even born i thought the
headset scanned your retinas and matched
them with your parallel universe cell so
why would the headset go through
parallel universes where summer doesn't
exist
also if these goggles also land on
realities you don't exist in they would
be rendered basically unusable with
infinitely possible universes the
chances of you landing on one you
actually exist in is infinitesimally
small
a mexican armada shows up and their
ships are sombreros
seems kind of racist alien invasion
tomato monster mexican armada brothers i
felt a great disturbance in the force as
if millions of sins suddenly cried out
in terror and were suddenly silenced
it's called two brothers two brothers
it's just called
i don't know what i like best about this
episode but hearing justin roiland laugh
at his own bull
might be the most honest and funniest
part but leaving in the laughter of you
cracking yourself up seems a bit
distracting and over the fourth wall
line even for this show so
know this hurts me more than it hurts
you and i'd be on dicaprio's yacht
banging kristen stewart since these
goggles are directly connected
to the dna of the person watching
shouldn't it disconnect once removed
from the scan
we just discovered a show called ball
fondlers but you guys clearly backed the
wrong conceptual horse
yeah but ball fondlers is just the
a-team could watch regular limited cable
to watch that
fakedoors.com is our website this
website doesn't work which seems like a
scent until you realize it is owned by
the company that owns rick and morty so
it could be an inside joke
about how just like the doors and the ad
don't open neither does the website or
it could be because this is an alternate
universe so the website wouldn't exist
in this one like with many rick and
morty observations i'm left wondering if
it was accidental oversight or
intentional genius but here's a sin
anyway since it made my head do hurty
brain thinking
huh he's making himself a sandwich now
this top piece of bread has nothing on
it which means he has put the peanut
butter on a slice of bread and then
jellied on top of the peanut butter one
ingredient per slice you monster also he
sets the dirty knife directly on the
countertop it can put up with a lot in
this world but people who set dirty
utensils on the counter can go straight
to helmets
still here still selling fake doors this
might be one of the funniest things they
watch on infinity tv but what kind of
world is it where a guy who sells fake
doors can afford a commercial that runs
90 seconds or longer paid for by
trunk people man that trunk people
emblem seems really offensive but i
guess the
trunk people chose that no room is safe
from the turbulent power
of turbulent juice was that a movie or
like does it clean stuff
as usual morty would be amazing at tv
sense baby legs you're a good detective
but not good enough because of your baby
legs i'm totally down with a random vibe
of infinite cable possibilities but why
would
baby legs wear a diaper is this guy an
adult but like a baby can't control when
he goes to the bathroom
so i'm partnering you up with regular
legs is everyone with regular legs named
regular legs or does this guy's leg
stand out amongst his peers as the most
regular which would be a contradiction
in terms
also this feels like an average everyday
weird cartoon you can already find on
cartoon network it's in the same vein as
assy mcgee
here we go that's the sound i make when
i'm trying to run fast
this is basically bec bennett's office
boss character and when you're stealing
from 2013 snl
you may want to rethink your sketch
premises that out there
that's my grave wow those graves are so
freshly dug and moundy that it's pretty
incredible no one from this family has
stumbled upon them these graves are more
obvious than the ones ron perlman sees
at the end of the last supper
nobody exists on purpose nobody belongs
anywhere everybody's gonna die come
watch tv
if 2019 were a movie this would be the
tagline on the poster
2019. mrs sullivan always planned to
leave
everything to her cats i understand this
is infinite cable but why does rick
somehow
always end up on a movie trailer rather
than simply a movie oh
mrs oh sullivan wow this movie this
g-rated what does it need to even get to
a pg not to mention r but i imagine in
their world gasparnoy finds ways to push
the envelope
i guess jerry ate someone else's toe
because all his toes are intact in the
shot while
this reflection in the bird cage gives
us a perfect image of a sad bet the
reflection itself seems completely
impossible given the pov
and it doesn't even appear to reflect
the cage itself oh come on
as if the odds weren't astronomical
enough that they would even land on
anything about themselves both jerry and
beth happen to land on the same reality
i've never stopped thinking about what
might have been wow a pretty unexpected
heartfelt whammy at the end of this
episode full of randomness this show was
so good
hey rick i have to make a project for
the science fair this weekend
you think you could help me out science
fairs well i mean
traditionally science fairs are a
father-son thing
so girls never have to participate in
science fairs that's unfair fair
and racist eating pancakes with butter
and no syrup
oh my god a brand new sentient robot
would say oh my gears
just saying whatever this guy is doing
balancing plates on thin air
i see they fixed the shelf but they
changed the animation so add another sin
i make my own stuff and the animators
make their stuff up on the spot too
the skull candle and a floating elephant
carcass
are brand new additions to this counter
i'm a man of science
and i'm a man who likes consistency why
is the elephant in a jar over here now
not to start a whole another gif gift
debate but does the glue have a label on
it claiming to be sticky
giz or jizz but
you know spelled with a g for some
reason why do we have to corrupt
glue why does glue have to be perverted
being limber enough to flop your legs on
the floor like this without pulling any
ligaments or dislocating your pelvis
jerry was inside the house and could
have walked through this door to the
garage but instead circles outside to
the garage to enter in dramatic fashion
is he smart enough to think about
entering for dramatic flair this
aftershave made women want me but it
also made me impotent
oh my god how can i not see this coming
because because you're impotent
the serum should counteract the negative
effects injecting someone with your
serum without their explicit consent
i like my devil fights to have a lot
more finger zapping and brimstone and a
lot less back and forth slapping
so what was the ironic punishment for
buying the vase how does a scary ghost
go along with your theme
this vase helps your flower stay alive
but it's also haunted is a joke that
steps on the theme and you're just being
lazy
i'm king flippy nips ruler of pluto
we discovered you quite by accident
which is interesting because pluto was
also discovered quite by accident it was
when saturn was going in and out of
uranus and then about to hook up with
neptune
you really gave it to those guys at nasa
the plutonians abduct jerry so that he
can declare pluto a planet and i'm sure
that's amazing for their egos and all
but why do they think jerry has any sway
over the rest of earth didn't they hear
how nasa responded
this is what you do when your b story
has nowhere else to go
well i'm going to get the curses removed
at curse purge plus
you know the guy on tv and of course
rick is on the television right this
second because tv show has to news
position
but why she could have just as easily
said you know the store across the
street
as we find out that's where it is in
just a second also this tv wasn't even
on 20 seconds ago
[Applause]
but how exactly did rick get a store
bought up so fast rick is not the devil
he can't just make a store appear
overnight
also how is the shopping district if
first in maine had a vacancy
also also how did rick know mr needful
was going to this window at this exact
moment the center of pluto mr smith is
made of a substance called plutonium
pluto exposition pluto's position
explodocition
pluto goes from planet to asteroid to
meteor
and finally a great visual truly but
where did the pluto dust come from his
hands were empty a moment ago
oh my god that's the devil summer i wish
this desk was lighter
absolutely none of the wishes summer
makes on the monkey's paw come with any
backfiring curses
what a waste of a monkey poor but how
would mr needful know this
he was passed out while summer was
making her wishes mr needful how could
you even think of doing something so
horrible
i'm the devil can the devil even kill
himself if he's the devil it implies he
sort of lives forever
right i can take out the eternity and
the padding and then you'll have some
time traveling mittens
and at what point does anyone ask what
the cost for the item will be
these items are literally priceless and
not in a good way
i just got bored everybody out how
jeremy in cinemas in staff meetings
are you telling me four billion
plutonians are wrong
can we worry about that in just a second
because who's going to tell jerry to
stop putting scissors up his nose in a
moving vehicle
angry crowd suddenly has rotting food to
throw cliche
it was a long six hours but we've
overhauled needful things
into the globally compliant web 4.0
e-nominant needful.com investing in the
dot-com business in 2014
when exactly did jerry's roof get
repaired when the plutonians showed up
initially they pulled jerry and morty
through the roof causing a lot of damage
he dumped me summer wipes clumpy mascara
drippage from beneath her eyes with the
simple wipe of her hand
i mean that's the most unrealistic thing
to happen in this entire episode
repeating a cycle of violence
repetitively so
dad guess what tomorrow is the day you
return this horrific tablecloth to the
store
or stab it because it's an alien see it
changes patterns
it's absolutely an alien having trouble
holding a consistent geometric pattern
honestly this level of paranoia is a
direct result of watching too much rick
and morty
trust nothing everything is nothing or
something
umbrella paintings but also tomorrow is
your one year anniversary back in our
lives
celebrating arbitrary anniversaries
because you can i'm gonna make you
flying saucer-shaped pancakes
and yes as another rick points out
shortly regular shaped pancakes are also
flying saucer shapes so
this scene is for teasing that you're
making fun shaped pancakes when in fact
you are
not beth is a monster considering
breakfast is on the table i think we're
meant to believe it's 6 a.m and there's
no way this family has gathered for a
fully prepared meal by
6 [ __ ] a.m nope in this episode we
learned that rick smarty brainwaves need
morty's dummy brainwaves to keep rick
untraceable or some such [ __ ] yet
here in the opening credits he straight
up leaves morty to die
so what's that about our son's been
abducted you hate me for buying those
coins
to be fair jerry was frozen when morty
was abducted and therefore wouldn't
understand the full reason beth is upset
normally jerry deserves the yelling but
not this time beth also coin collections
jeez rick what is this place the citadel
of ricks
it's the secret headquarters for the
council of ricks and where's the
counseling center for jerry and beth's
considering all ricks have a morty and
all morty's have a jerry and beth who
would be distraught
because their sons are missing turn your
boring old morty into a
hot fashion statement this is a
ricktastic concept but he can see that
the ricky's trying to sell his goods to
has handcuffs on and is being
transported by some form of authority
right how does he expect to close a deal
here exactly
it's supposed to be funny because they
have different hair styles but it's not
cliche
if his body was stuffed into the wood
chipper starting with the head then how
is the arm still in one piece
yeah so does the scientist formerly
known as rick why isn't he here in
handcuffs because he's dead
too it's half cap shaming so as they say
in canada
p suit making fun of canadians wait is
that a sin
i can't remember ron morty and then our
rick and morty run by many other rick
and morties who would easily attempt to
stop
them but don't even try perplexing
considering everyone thinks our rick is
a dangerous rick killer but oh well
on to the portal pandemonium i feel like
this is a good time to revisit the how
the [ __ ] does the portal pew pew gun
work portion of the program
does he just think of a specific
destination or are the locations random
and somehow managed to spew fire
insects and tentacles at the perfect
moment the incredibly convenient timing
is simple either way
based on the fact that we only see asses
and no hands what is the purpose of the
giant rolls of toilet paper who would
even use them
and how are the rear ends so clean if
the ground around them is covered in
feces
this is the least subtle symbolic anal
penetration since the ending of north by
northwest
yeah i'd like to order one large person
with extra people please
white people no no no black people and
hispanic on half
racist pizza yes i'd like to order one
large sofa chair
this is a pretty funny running gag but
with all these different worlds it makes
me wonder why the rix looked the same at
the council or it was pizza rick or
telephone ricker greasy grandma rick and
we see a hammer morty later so clearly
these types exist i continue to take
issue with the use of portals in this
episode and here's why
rick splats out a whole bunch of options
the enemy appears and they say
they could have gone into any one of
these we lost them which means they
aren't tracking our rick and morty so
how would they have known to follow them
into the farty mcpoop smith world in the
first place
i just want to point out that there
appears to be a fruit bowl on the bottom
shelf which is a really dumb place for
fruit and bowls in the combination
thereof
anything else yeah more phone sticks
please so they're eating
phones just because they went into a
different dimension does not mean they
have a different digestive system
bad guys avoid looking around the room
thereby allowing the good guys to slip
away cliche
they look exactly like us so in order to
avoid confusion i'm gonna mark us each
with a red x right now
but they're also wearing different
clothing so you could just go with that
as the identifier
also there must be additional exits to
this restaurant because a rick and morty
straight up escape so rather than
marking
x's on foreheads perhaps watch those
doors
hey you didn't pay your bill you said
holy chairs are sentient
wrong advertising wow so people need
help figuring out what to buy and then
you help them it's a little more
complicated than that
it is not also if the other jerry's
think bulk jerry is useless why would he
be brought along for missions in the
first place
appears there are more than enough ricks
for the job you're missing my symphony
hey i'll take it over mumford and sons
i'm pretty sure the rolling stones
review for that mumford and sons album
was it's the equivalent of listening to
a thousand naked children being tortured
so this race might still be too close to
call we will find our peace
in the next world show now asks us to
believe that the captive mortys have had
enough time to form a cult and mine this
cave prison for the resources to create
cloaks printed propaganda and a precise
razor to shave their heads
the pointy thing isn't piercing morty
any longer and so all the tortured
mortys spend one beautiful second
believing they are freed before
realizing they are likely falling to
their death
how special owning a life is rough
poster that shows the golf ball on the
green
and barely any rough saved your ass all
right morty don't break an arm jerking
yourself off
i mean you can't really do that right
right
this is the receiver yeah but where's
the transmitter cliffhangers
no eye boogers glitters
[Music]
stalkers let's lose the tude please
losing
the tude speaking of disasters dad we
are leaving you in charge
yeah but that's kind of on beth right
why would she ever leave rick in charge
of her children or
really anything this shitty garage door
falls outwards after the center is
dissolved by alien eels
except the hinges weren't destroyed so
this is a sin for the animators not
making a couple of heels dissolve the
hinges and a sin for the writers for
forcing the door to fall in order to
kick off the rest of the episode well
we're past the point of no return
bridget fonda shaming using your binder
incorrectly or
writing math upside down and backwards
on the back panel of a binder for no
reason
either way us in does that say
multi-grain legs
i guess they sell peanuts in a box and
abbreviate legumes to legs
none of this seems appetizing more
profitable just keep your sci-fi friends
away from my awesome one
how about you all focus and just keep
that refrigerator door closed while you
carry on conversations and
then work on your strategic segregation
and you keep your awesome friends away
from my canapes
when the canopy tray came out of the
fridge every one of them had a green
olive
why would rick remove one just to add it
back in dramatic fashion
i love watching [ __ ] i mean like i
don't know if i personally would ever do
it
[ __ ] how many people did you invite
rick better question
of the many that rick invited how many
are going to want to get downstairs
schwifty with summer's questionably aged
peer group
looks like the garage door was instantly
fixed i love seeing aliens and humans
hanging out together despite their
differences but
how are none of the people freaking out
right now being a morty at a high school
party
casually watching a murder meal
knock it off slow mobius if slow mobius
didn't stop using his slo-mo powers
until rick said something why was rick
able to speak at a normal pace
running on deck also stealing this
[ __ ] doesn't feel solid objects in
his liquid and that
is [ __ ] concerning they weren't the
size of ants they were ice cube size
beings
summer don't tell me you're friends with
her popular controlling girl is pretty
and demands your normal looking friend
to be sacrificed on the altar of
conformity cliche
i just want to find somebody nice and
sweet which somehow prompts morty to
show her a deadly mad scientist garage
rather than the toy collection in his
room apparently the garage door wasn't
fixed in now i'm curious about the side
story where the door was dissolved by
eels fixed before the party but then
immediately redissolved tarped
taped tacked and held in place by bullsh
house teleports to a different planet
that happens to have oxygen an immediate
hook up to power
cliche you see jerry may i show you
something i was lucy not been caught yet
the operation doesn't seem to be that
large and she's wearing a maids outfit
no one has questioned why she's
fraternizing with a guest instead of
cleaning or picking up
rick's using a credit card to turn these
crystals into something snortable but
what's with the number on this thing
one two three four one two three four it
can't be a show that revels in the
details and then not expect a nitpicker
to examine stuff like this
come up with a plausible number you
jerks move to the left that's the right
step to the right that's the left
that somehow everyone knows instantly
also riverdance did it first
the floor drops out to make it easier
we're going to get it
nice and steamy in there with with the
floor kicked out
well at least you got all this free
stuff equating free stuff is an
agreeable result of being the victim of
a sexual assault it's not a door beth
it's debris
i don't care just leave it yeah okay
this door can fit in the front seat so
there's no reason it shouldn't be able
to fit in the back of their wagon with a
little rearranging
[Music]
somehow despite the window being down in
the ear piercing volume of her horrible
laugh
neither of these [ __ ] hear her
explaining your references
since everything came back as it
previously was where did the rest of
this gate go
pulling down someone's pants while they
are frozen midstep wouldn't be this easy
in reality these pants would get stuck
at the waist and top of the thigh
don't ask me how i know this not using
the ramp for your cart filled with
expensive electronics
and yes it is stolen but it's still
valuable
not until i hear you say rixxy business
or rick and morty rick
not until
why is this boner
jesus grandpa what did you read me this
thing for a very nosy fella kitty cat
huh you know what happens to nosey
fellas
do you want me to buy a subscription to
the saturday evening post no
not a word not a word not a word now i
went into a future dimension with such
advanced medicine
that they had broken legs here i'm at
every corner drugstore i'm sure that in
1985
plutonium is available in every corner
drugstore but in 1955
it's a little hard to come by he's got
some kind of disability or something is
that what you want us to say
i do implausible i know but i like to
imagine that he had sex the night before
and now a little bit of residue is
blocking his urethra
oh geez dad you know that's a lot to
drop on a kid all at once
[Music]
oh my god he's trying to tell us
something that is so
awesome
[Music]
sexual hang-ups in the pleasure chamber
are punishable by death
with their heads you will walk when it
is time
to walk you got that [ __ ]
i'll come back tomorrow maybe they'll be
gone by then you better get out of here
before somebody sees us
introducing smart dogs
the first dogs trained to train humans
mr spicoli you're on dangerous ground
here you're causing a major disturbance
on my time
are you saying there's something wrong
with my gear get to the digestive tract
he's coughing
i'm possessed
here comes the drums
oh my god it looks like a huge
pekka wait a word
looks like someone private
there's always a bigger fish sigerian
scammers morty the galaxy's most
ambitious
least successful con artist that doesn't
make sense we're good streaky
look at that old lady she's she's
walking a cat on a leash
yes see you in 10 minutes i'm gonna go
home and sleep with my wife
and those words on your dick aren't
gonna go away
unless you start using topical cream
every day
i'm a white boy but my neck is red i put
miracle whip on my wonder bread
well we're back to our roots driving the
same streets my grandfather started on
oh the times were simpler back then
weren't they because
people had integrity i looked at the
trap ray
you're out of order you're out of order
the whole
trial is out of order i've dreamt of
free solo cap for 10 years
and every year it just looked too big
you've come to fight as three man
and three men you are what will you do
without freedom
buckle up you're your driver is a snail
hey jessica hello peter
what's happening i throw balls far i'm
gonna
oh yo you know son
you're not a kid anymore oh no i go to
health class dad i already know all this
stuff
but what people call love is just a
chemical reaction that compels animals
to breed
biochemically no different than eating
large
quantities of chocolate there's
something special about you morty
you reached out and you touched it by
the heart
rip my clothes off and mate with me for
life it's really important in this pose
that you arch your back and keep it flat
at the same time
you're you're you're just a little
creepy creep person you're just this
penny stealing wannabe criminal
man
so we're just going to pretend this
isn't happening i'm not saying that's a
bad idea just asking
i drive a dodge stratus
i think i hit puberty should i cut the
cord
i think it's linguine can't take this
anymore
i learned it by watching you i came here
to do
two things eat eggs and nothing
and i'm not out of either will you
please
not marry me i choose veronica but
imagine if he came back with something
actually useful for the girl and then he
came back two minutes later
with some self-respect and some dignity
but one of us
is dead corn ah no the corn
paul newman's gonna have my legs broke
this
is delicious you eat pieces for
breakfast
it says you can't eat anymore
definitely tell you what friends if
nobody comes down and buys a car for me
the next hour
i'm gonna club this baby seal that's
right
i'm gonna club and see i'm gonna make a
better deal you know i'll do it too
cause i'm crazy man woman
and now trunk men man you must be out of
your mind if you think i'm gonna get in
this dirty ass trunk
hi i'm a trunk person i am not
an animal i am a human being
what is my purpose i brought you into
this world
a machine that can think and feel
[Laughter]
we are laughing
i want an apology nay nay i demand
penance you're watching right side of
the bed i'm grayson chisholm
take him to plutonium bay you can't
handle the truth
homer i told you this morning no guns at
the dinner table
you no no no
[Applause]
[Music]
and i hate to get all andy rooney about
it but when did bright colored plastic
cows
pigs and rabbits get to be art coffee
time
you wake up it's time for coffee
advertising
wow so people need help figuring out
what to buy and then
you help them cheese it's milk
that you chew you know jerry i'm not
gonna tell you that these will increase
in value or even hold their current
value
the truth is you bought them because you
like them they have value to you
that's what matters
i don't want them to gain another yard
you blitz all night
speaking of disasters dad we are leaving
you in charge
ooh someone has a serious face on
it smells like thai food in here have
you guys been [ __ ]
every weekend jackson roses have their
titanic experience in this car
and i have to mop it up oh that's not
right
i'm still alive but i'm very badly
injured the beacon was activated
and rohan will answer